welcome everybody i am really delighted
that you've come out here for the first
of our speaker series events this week
that's being co-sponsored
by the yale climate and energy institute
and the yale
center for environmental law and policy
my name is doug kaiser i teach at the
law school i'm inter interim director of
the center for environmental law and
policy i'm delighted that mark pagani
the director of ycei is here as well
we are kicking off a series of four
events this semester
that we've called the c words
talking about addressing climate change
without talking about climate change and
you can probably immediately understand
the political context that's motivated
that theme and we have a great speaker
to kick off our first event of the
semester i'm going to introduce the
associate director of yselp who will
introduce our speaker um the associate
director has been working alongside our
climate and energy fellow bruce ho
just wave your hand thanks
the associate director is named joshua
galperin uh josh and bruce have been
putting together this speaker series and
uh josh is the as i said the new
associate director of yslp he's a
graduate of vermont law school and the
mem program here at fvs we're very
excited to have him on board at the
center so without further ado josh
okay folks thanks for coming i'll try to
be real brief in my introduction because
kiara has a lot of good things to say so
let me just start by saying that this is
a talk it's about pr that's what chiari
does and we did make one of the fatal pr
mistakes which is
putting a few people in a very big room
this is actually i think a really good
turnout but we're in you know bowers and
that means it looks a little smaller
than it is but i assure you there's a
lot of people here learning so this is
actually this is good and it looks
better than i thought it would um so let
me tell you real quickly how i know
chiari and how i thought of bringing her
on board here i used to work at a group
in uh based in knoxville tennessee
called the southern alliance for clean
energy and uh on in my waning days there
we were working on a project to try to
reform the alabama power company which
is a very heavily co-dependent utility
and of course coal equals climate change
and um we knew that we could not talk
about climate change when we were trying
to convince people in alabama that they
had to start thinking about how their
electricity was generated and why their
electricity rates were as high as they
were and and we knew this had to be a
conversation about something other than
climate change it had to be about a
number of things finance
personal choice um
saving money whatever it was it couldn't
be climate change so we ran into uh
chiari and and one of her colleagues
eric frankowski and they said we would
love to get involved in this effort so
um we we engaged with resource media
chiari's group where she is a vice
president and works on the um climate
energy issues climate energy and
environment issues for resource media
and they came in and gave us all these
great ideas about how to deal with
climate problems in alabama specifically
but without talking about the climate
problems that we're trying to address so
chiari was a huge help in getting that
off the ground and i don't know how it's
proceeded because i left and maybe
carrie will have something to say about
that in this talk i'm not sure but um
but the great part was not just all the
knowledge that chiari brought to the
table but the actual enthusiasm she
brought a lot of us working in the
southeast we got pretty down pretty
quickly uh and it became hard to be
really enthusiastic about what we were
doing but chiari came in and she was you
know smiling and happy and at one point
for some reason i don't really remember
somebody at the group handed out pipe
cleaners like you know they wanted us to
say if you have something to distract
yourself with tactilely while we're
having this discussion then you'll focus
better and by the end of the discussion
chiari had made um this little sort of
mole insect thing that i actually had to
like have because i wanted to bring it
to my wife because i thought it was
adorable and i gave it to her as a gift
and it's still sitting in my house uh or
my apartment back in knoxville which we
still have unfortunately so anyway where
it went yeah
so it's in knoxville and chiari is here
so um i hope that her enthusiasm is
infectious to all of you and you learn
something here and kiari thank you very
much for joining us nice thank you that
was a really good introduction i love
the stories we're going to talk more
about storytelling later but that's what
people probably remember more is when
you tell a story about someone or about
something so
hopefully when you leave the room you'll
remember that i'm good at making pipe
cleaner animals
that's my goal that's the only goal of
my presentation but thank you thank you
josh
let's get just the logistics out of the
way who am i what am i doing here just
gave you a good intro a lot of the work
that we do at resource media is
just about finding common connections to
communicate better across shared values
that people have and we work
predominantly around environmental
issues and public health issues so we
get to choose and that
goes across everything from energy
efficiency renewable energy toxics
coal as we were talking about coal fire
power plant retirement coal export
you name it water water health clean
water
public land all of those things are
really communication challenges but at
the end of the day it's about finding
the things that connect people or
connect people emotionally to something
and sending messages out so we help
people do a better job at that and
that's why i love my job it's very
difficult we work with a whole host of
different kinds of people from analysts
scientists advocates
community members city planners just to
help them all connect the dots they're
trying to connect so
that said
let's move right along um i have a lot
of i guess the first step here is going
to be
moving the slides here we go so i have a
lot of slides and my goal is to engage
so as i told folks when they were early
words i'm going to pick on people in the
audience so that we can have more of a
dialogue and i'm not talking at you i'm
sort of talking with you kind of
um so the presentation is really going
to show you a few major things how
people understand climate change um
basically
your message and then some elements of
what works and what we know doesn't work
so well the lessons learned
so
how people understand climate change in
general if you're trying to communicate
about climate change or not communicate
about it the best thing is just to look
at what you know about who you're
talking to
and you know a lot of times in
communications we turn to public opinion
research and a lot of the great work
that people do and i'm starting of
course in your backyard because a lot of
the best work has been done here
and um in communications it's not about
necessarily just the best message it's
about the best message for the right
audiences and you have to understand
what people actually listen to
and what they hear
and thinking about how to craft your
language in a way that resonates
directly with who you're trying to reach
so a lot of times you know you'll run
into friends and colleagues who are
skeptical about climate change
definitely not here
but in the world um you you find that
more and more in different places like
it was margaret who's from the midwest
right where are you from again
iowa
so in iowa do you think you're going to
run into a lot of skeptics
for sure for sure and a lot of times
it's not just saying forget it they you
know don't get it it's about figuring
out how to reach them and you know
cognitive research shows that when you
have a contra controversial topic where
you know people have different kinds of
views you have to figure out what are
their ideologies what can i resonate
with what are their values and when you
come in that door you can find that
those people will actually listen to a
message that they might turn off from so
really a lot of the the starting points
are around what you actually know and
you know dan connor i think we you know
i hope you know who he is
raise your hand if you know who he is
okay
good that's good news
in a way because if you don't i'm
actually engaging you in the experts
that are in your backyard so he with the
with the cultural cognition project is
doing a lot of great work in figuring
out how to resonate with people and
really how to present
present information or facts that are
not counter to people's values or
ideologies by understanding you know how
we can sink in with where people are we
always stay at resource media you're not
going to be as successful trying to
bring people where you are until you
meet them where you are where they are
so in figuring out how you meet people
where you are you have to understand
and figure out what you know about how
they hear information or receive
information so
here we go we're going to start talking
about the difference between
persuasive communication and educational
communication
so
tyler
if i just asked you what's the
difference between persuasive
communication and educational
communication what would you
and pressure to get think to do
something
and education communication is just
trying to give them the most relevant
information
education
yeah educational communication trying to
give them the most
good i think that's generally it and i
would just take the word force out of
there and say you know persuasive
communication is about
basically trying to get a response by
communicating something
and it that could be a change in
behavior a change in attitude
some specific type of action
and
educational information educational
communications like you said is really
to inform people to make sure you're
getting the information out in the right
way
and you're really looking for what we
call reach and frequency and not
necessarily measuring a response so
reach and frequency and communications
is how many people i might have reached
by sending out my message by sending out
my information
and how often i'm sending it out so
that's how you know you're informing
versus persuasive communications where
you're saying am i causing a change am i
producing some kind of change in
attitude change in belief action so
we're really talking about two different
things and a lot of the communication
that we see around environment and
public health is to get people to do
something to put pressure on policy
makers so the persuasive communications
ideally so you're trying to counter
existing beliefs and get people to
possibly change them or do something
so
here's a sort of golden rule in in
persuasive communications it's not
necessarily
what you say
um that's important but it's who says it
so if i was saying that the messenger is
important menu what would you think that
means
the message is important but what about
the messenger
exactly so use a great word around this
trustworthy or credible
so it's you know if you're trying to
reach farmers let's say
and and really to help them see the link
between climate change and drought and
its effect on their their crops their
pla their planting patterns all of those
things you know me coming out there
being perceived sometimes as a as a
climate advocate or a
wacky enviro i may not be the best
messenger but there are farmer champions
who get this
who you leverage to deliver a message so
it's that golden rule of not just think
about what you're gonna say think about
who should be saying it and a lot of the
work we do is about getting folks to
know they're not the right messenger and
to figure out the strategy behind not
just what you say to reach people or
change people persuade people but who
should say it
so that's a really important piece of
the work
i don't know if any of you have read
this article
raise your hand if you've seen this
article
now this article is a recent article
that was in the stanford um social
innovation
review
uh and my
alma mater so i'm going to use this
first i'm talking about you guys more
later
but you know it really is a great
article and i i recommend it to all of
you because it touches on
the the sort of cultural aspect of this
the politicism of climate change and
what you do about it what we know about
it and what you can do about it so this
article really um you know it talks
about how
you know even beneficial information
can for people can be hazardous by the
way you present it people will perceive
things read things in certain ways but
it really confronts that you know
in when you look at the world view
of folks
sometimes the the folks who are making
decisions about what to say
they don't understand that not everyone
shares their worldview
and i think that's one the most
important part of it making decisions in
communication it's both being informed
and also knowing you're likely not
sharing the world view of the people
that you're trying to reach perhaps you
are if you're trying to reach your base
let's say you're trying to reach more
folks within the environmental movement
to get them to do something then you are
you know preaching to the choir or
trying to expand the choir from just the
soprano section to an alto section an
obese section in a tenor section but a
lot of cases were we're essentially
trying to move not just the choir but
the folks possibly sitting on the fence
or the folks who might jump on the fence
and that's a different story altogether
so you know this article really talks
about you know how you can look at the
differences in how people perceive
climate change and how you look at sort
of how the the world views and create
different concept concepts of science of
climate information by looking at how
people receive information so i
recommend this article
um
i i'm not going to give all the goodies
away but it's something i think
everybody should read and it's a little
lengthy i just want to warn you
um
so in terms of public opinion research
who knows what that means or how would
you define that
jorge
public opinion public opinion research
if i just said that what would it mean
to you
exactly exactly and it's fundamental
to communications around climate because
when you know we refer to it as the c
words
now because we've learned from public
opinion research that when people hear
the term climate change they have all
these preconceived notions and sometimes
they're negative
and sometimes they're positive sometimes
it's just i have no idea what that means
and i'm going to nod my head and pretend
so you really want to understand what
people's attitudes are what they think
and don't think about certain things so
public opinion research is so key
and what we've learned and i'm gonna
actually give you some practical
applications of this
um through public opinion research
okay is more about how we reach people
by figuring out what we know about them
so starting in your own backyard i just
want to highlight some public opinion
research that's come right out of here
and who's seen the six america study
yay
this is so valuable and it's valuable
for a couple of reasons one because it
it's done more than once and you can see
change over time but it also gives you a
sense of the different segments of folks
in america who you're talking to
and if you look at hello
here we go
if you look at
persuasive communications across the six
americas you can see here that the study
does a really good job in categorizing
six major categories of people
and you see the folks that are alarmed
concerned cautious disengaged doubtful
dismissive and if you look at this and
you can see the changes this is from
2009 it changes over the course of the
year and wonder you know what does that
mean for the different groups
who actually has
worked on this or has intimate knowledge
of this study
what's your name
now what do you think are some of the
key takeaways
just in your opinion thinking about how
important this is
need to sort of look at a deeper level
than this top line level for sure to
understand how to message to these
various people so that you can get in
and determine what their values are and
there were some fairly consistent things
at the end at the various
okay you should be up here because
that's exactly right i think there are
the big buckets but really to understand
how to persuade people and move people
you have to dive deeper into
understanding what are their values
what do they care the most about and you
know this is a great study to sort of
start you off and and really give you
the mass message of you really need to
understand more about each audience and
you know we we say a lot there's no such
thing as the sort of
the general public
because when you're talking to the
general public or investing in campaigns
that are to the general public you're
wasting your money
because what you really want to do is
figure out who are you really trying to
move will you know about what moves and
what they care the most about and then
talk exactly towards that so i'll get
into campaigns that we did that around
climate um in a second but the other the
other thing that public opinion research
can show you is the regional differences
in what people think and when we look at
climate change global warming as a very
serious problem you know there's some
interesting things about the south
and
if you're talking to folks if you're
doing a regional campaign it's pretty
important to look at regional
differences as well because you're not
speaking the same language across the
different parts of the country
so here's some more public opinion
research
so one of the things when we were
talking to folks in the southeast
josh will attest to this the good news
is actually the number when you look at
the south um the number here surprised
me when i looked at this this research
because that's not something you
actually
think about that the folks in the south
actually have a pretty high percentage
of excuse me believing that there's
evidence that the climate is changing
the climate is warming sorry excuse me
so the other thing that public opinion
research will show you is the
differences across party lines and
that's particularly important this year
because to break through
in sending messages and this is what i
think you guys recognized the most here
you have to really figure out what
the the focus of the media frame is
going to be right now it's the election
a lot of the coverage people are are
thinking about how which candidate
stands for what they're just talking
about things in the political context in
an election year
so looking at the differences across
party lines for the things that you're
trying to communicate about is
particularly important
so
here's some more it actually shows you
the changes over time as well so then
you try to figure out why have things
increased decreased why are people
changing their opinions what's happened
in the year to make this
change or this fluctuation occur
one thing that recently came out raise
your hand if you've seen this
awesome oh
well great the three people raised their
hands but awesome because everybody
should check this out again this is your
backyard it's a really interesting piece
about
voters and their opinions about climate
change so
you know it's self-evident
the differences here
i think this makes sense um
but what
actually is pretty important is looking
at the um undecided voters it's the big
seven percent
so why is understanding more about
people who haven't made up their mind
important to anyone communicating about
climate especially a candidate
what's your name
okay why did you think understanding
more about undecided voters would be
important
you're absolutely right it's because
they're probably the ones that can be
swayed right if you're trying to
persuade people if they're not sure i
mean you have folks on this side that
know they're voting for this guy or
folks on this side i'm i'm settled here
i'm not moving for whatever reasons the
folks you want to focus on are the folks
who you can persuade and particularly
that climate is an important part of the
discussion the undecideds understanding
more about what they think about this is
is pretty important and they actually
look a lot like the likely obama voters
and this study shows you a lot more
about that but if obama let's say wanted
to
move more people his way who are
undecided he needs to clarify let's say
his platform on climate on clean energy
on those things that these people
reportedly care about so figuring out
you know persuasive communications
figuring out what to say to actually
move people or change their attitudes
particularly important
so here again it's just showing you the
support for declining fossil fuels this
is something that has been a hot button
issue but here's where people agree
actually across lines
which is which is interesting
and declining fossil fuels investing in
renewable resources this is sort of the
solution solutions message that we'll
talk a little bit about
um okay so thinking about message
i have lunch with some fabulous students
this afternoon uh none of which i see in
the room
um i think i just told him everything i
wanted to know uh and we talked a lot
about uh effective messages and the key
is telling a story
and you know i had some folks in there
that say i'm really interested in
storytelling as a part of communications
around the environment and climate
and you know being clear about what's at
stake when you're talking about climate
it's not even necessarily talking about
you know the planet
could you know you could not live on the
planet in 50 years or 60 years it's
what's at stake for an individual person
it's what's at stake for a community
member it's what's at stake for a
community so figuring out how to tell
the story includes figuring out what's
at stake and how to communicate that
using analogies and and just simple
comparisons all of these things up here
you can you can
assume make a lot of sense but this one
you're nodding okay
we have a problem here
this is very hard to do for folks likely
in this room and who are scientists and
who tend to be the messengers on climate
when you look at the other side they're
very very good at keeping things very
short very consistent resonating
directly with folks sound bites and
those things in a soundbite nation that
are actually more effective
so figuring out a way to
make things more concise and to resonate
more with folks has been a big challenge
especially when it's complex information
so if you're talking about impacts and
you're using you know science as the
foundation for your message you're
already behind the eight ball because
other times folks are just not and
they're not using the facts they're not
explaining things well they're just
doing the things that fly over the
surface and they know will emotionally
connect so that's a big challenge
and we're going to talk about some ways
to do that but you know a great recipe
for creating a message in our mind is
values problem solutions so
building an emotional connection
describing a clear threat you know the
one two and three but ending on a
solution
so
how many times have you heard about
climate impacts and
been left with a feeling of oh
that is
not good
and then
that's it there you are
all right now what um so that's the
problem as well okay
it's figuring out how to tell a story
that
might not have a good ending but
figuring out how to tell a story that
ends with something that people can do
something that is going to happen or
could happen that's the solution side of
it
so i want that in my life and people
for hundreds of years have told that
kind of a story that's what resonates
with people is not just the bad what's
you know the threat but what's the
solution here
so you know telling real stories with
with real consequences is important and
when you look at the the sort of climate
story and talking about that in a way
that makes sense to people and is in the
story tell me about the impacts in
things that i can make decisions around
so
knowing more about sea level rise
will help me make decisions about where
my summer retirement home will be
located so that i feel empowered to
actually using this information for a
solution
that i can a problem i can solve in my
world but also can be this the starting
point for me to figure out what do i do
in general about this so you look at
where are the connections the things
people care about i care about where i'm
going to retire maybe i want to be on
the coast of florida or some other place
where i might not
be able to afford insurance down the
line so figuring out those kinds of ways
to connect with what people know and the
risks part of it as well people are used
to making decisions in their life that
are based around risk
you know when i'm buying insurance i
know i might not hit a car but i know i
need that insurance
for things that may not happen but could
happen in my life so it's not even about
convincing people that the climate
science story is a done deal everybody
agrees because that's where there is
some controversy but everybody agrees
it's a there's a big risk
and figuring out how to communicate that
because that is a frame that people know
and make decisions around in their lives
and change their attitudes about things
change their behavior around things
so figuring out what are the connections
that you can make
and again going back to the story so
stories versus facts i think people are
um
far more likely to read a newspaper
story that tells a story that has a hero
and a villain
and a conflict that's trying to be
resolved and an ending and a happy
ending is usually what people want as
well
so thinking about this and you know this
has been thousands and thousands of
years of myths and the way we know we
can communicate is tell a story to
people
and this is something we need to figure
out and part of the story um
is talking about the good guys and the
bad guys and one of the
students that i had lunch with made
just a spectacular point we can get
really good about telling the story of
the bad guys the koch brothers big oil
big bad you know coal
um but we don't do a good job about
identifying the heroes or making the
climate heroes seem cool
so we talked a little bit about you know
a new justice league of climate
champions in the sense that you know we
don't
really
identify the climate scientists with the
hero
or the folks like you
who are trying to find the next best
solution to some of the technological
challenges as the hero folks like me
that can connect more young not really
that young
african-american people to working in
this field and seeing it as something
that can make a difference but also
something where you learn something new
every day those kinds of next generation
climate heroes we need to figure out how
to make them cool
because right now that is not happening
as much as we're investing in figuring
out how to make the big bad guy so
that's another area that a student here
brought up to me today we really need to
do a better job at formulating that hero
in people's minds and not just telling
the story about the threat the story
about the big bad guys but who are we
so
another thing here um when you say
simplify
a lot of people and particularly folks
working on the anal the analysis side
feel like that means dumbing things down
so a lot of times when you're delivering
a message about impacts about threats
about coal and and public health impacts
people feel like
you know
if i'm if i've got to simplify that
means that i've gotta take it to a level
where people just you know are gonna get
it but that really challenges the
credibility of the science not not true
it's really i think people can grasp
complex concepts
as long as you present them in a way
that resonates again it's not dumbing
down the science it's not dumbing down
the facts
the other thing here
i want to point out what's your name ben
do you think that
people have become in our sort of
technological society more
or
less attentive to longer messages
exactly i am also the queen of
multitasking so i don't fault you for
that if i was in the room i'd probably
be doing stuff and hiding it you know
because we're in that kind of sound bite
society multitasking society where
people have you have to connect you have
shorter time to do it people are getting
a percentage of what you're saying and
if you're not saying it in the most
powerful way that you know can reach
them you know why spend your time so i
think that's an important point to make
here is that you have less time to make
your point
don't again
make your
answer so long your message so long your
story's so long 140 characters just
kidding um so the other thing in making
the human connection
um
connecting to those values we talked
about the values that people share and
thinking about how when you're trying to
communicate about environmental
causes technology you need to resonate
with all of these and one that's that's
not on here that i have been noticing
more and more it's that sense of
american just looking at america
american ingenuity in that we're we're
feeling like we're slipping from being
the country that's out in front that's
developing the next technology that's
you know
going to the moon solving the climate
crisis tapping into american sense of
wanting to be the best wanting to be the
place where people come to research this
to develop new things that sense of
ingenuity is also something that we need
to tap into to get people in the door
and then try to connect more and get
them motivated to find more information
so that's one thing that is important
and now i'm going to look at a couple of
campaigns i know the reason why i'm here
essentially is about
talking about climate without using the
c words
the other thing that came up at lunch
which i know is probably a part of your
water cooler or whatever you probably
don't have watercolors your study room
conversation
at the you know
fast food place here i don't know
but a part of that conversation is
whether to even
use the words at all
that is still up for debate i know i
have a lot of heated conversations with
the folks that i work with and
i think it's yes and no my answer i
think there are a lot of places where
you don't want to use the c words and
then there are a lot of places where you
want to bring them along for the ride
and start connecting that dot because
it's true at the end of the day if
people are afraid of using the term
climate change
then
we have a lot more work to do than just
the technology so really getting that
comfort level higher in places it's not
they're just not ready they're not even
you know they're so raw they're not even
ready to go in the oven but i i do feel
think that there's got to be that
parallel universe so looking at place
looking at types of campaigns that
actually don't use the c word who knows
anything about the sort of coal export
challenge
how would you quantify
what's your name sir
jim
how would you quantify what that
challenge is right now for coal export
just tell me what you think about it
what do you think we're dealing with
right now
ports on the western coast shipping
there's material overseas that would be
burned and create climate change
perfect local air pollution
perfect perfect perfect
and you know we were working on
a for lack of better term campaign that
focused on
all of these proposed terminals
and
for exporting coal
we were looking at what's going to be
the most effective
messaging strategy communication
strategy around this
and surprise surprise it was not climate
it was not the consequences globally of
exporting coal it was actually
more around the
basic community impact
and
folks that would be impacted on health
and safety levels by sitting behind
big coal trains
and i used to live in an area that was
right around a refinery and i've sat
behind
trains that are
literally miles long for 15 20 minutes
and
you're multitasking
you're you know playing games on your
phone you're calling people you even
turn the car off because it makes no
sense to sit idle when you're gonna be
sitting for a while and the big safety
issue is what if i had an emergency
there would be no way to get around this
train
there would be no way to get my child to
a hospital so that's one thing it's just
the the safety issue the inconvenience
issue i'm a busy person even when i've
got nowhere to go i'm a busy impatient
person and i hate just sitting
waiting on a train
so
you know i'm ready to go i'm ready to go
do whatever i need to do even if it's
absolutely nothing important
but me losing 10 15 20 minutes behind
coal trains is not
not my friend yes
absolutely
with different messaging that was
targeting
people here in connecticut that had some
kind of influence on federal legislation
it just
it seems like there's always that debate
what grabs the local
a local constituency and what what will
grab a national
yeah i think that's a really really good
question because oftentimes we talk
about we get folks coming to us to say i
want to impact the dc
the audience so do you have folks in dc
we have a dc office but that's usually
not actually the strategy it's moving
the constituencies
that these folks represent to put
pressure on the way they're making
decisions because a lot of times the
folks making decisions if it's you know
the community voting to have this or if
it's the decision maker that's voting at
the federal level that's representing
you guys in dc it's about you guys and
them feeling like they're going to get
reelected or not so
oftentimes it's both but you go for that
local figuring out how to communicate
from the local constituency to their
representative we care about this and if
you vote for this
you know guess what you're not going to
be back here or you're not going to be
back there
so it's it's a combination of both so
often times it's that local strategy
that moves that dc policy maker and
looking here you know it was that
community local community issue it was
also at the end of the so first it was
safety inconvenience you know we're all
impatient tap into that impatience
but then it was the public health the
ash that's falling coal ash that's
falling off trains it's in your water
it's in your face
and you know also using and this is
another piece about how to do this
effectively using the right images so
you know moving coal is a dirty
dangerous and
in some cases if you look at that woman
loud situations so you look at this
coal train that's passing by this
restaurant
who wants that
um and who wants that for 10 25 minutes
when they're there to enjoy lunch
and the other thing that factored into
this campaign was also the
untrustworthiness of the coal companies
and looking at people's sense of
fairness tapping into that feeling that
these guys aren't playing
on you know they're putting profit
before people
and and if if it's a job story we can do
a better job
than this if we're trying to create jobs
this is not the way to do it
so it's it's a lot of those different
kinds of factors when you're thinking
about what to talk about
and at the end of the day climate really
didn't enter into the picture
so
knowing more again the public opinion
research helps a lot of the campaigns so
josh referenced a coal fire power plant
retirement campaign we've been working
with an alliance of of different groups
who seven years ago were focused on
fighting new coal finding proposed power
plants and in that case it was messaging
where you're choosing between
new dirty instead of new clean so why
choose if you're going for something new
to put in the ground steel in the ground
why not a new
wind farm or why not new solar farm or
why not you know new different ways to
combine efficiency with something
cleaner
why choose a new coal plant if you're
going to invest millions of dollars
so that was actually
a challenge that we're quite successful
with with the right kind of messaging
and messengers
now the movement quote unquote is
looking at taking existing coal plants
offline
so
why would you think many that started
picking on you again that that would be
harder
ding ding ding
that's right because now you're looking
at stuff that's already a part of the
community this coal plant is sponsoring
little league teams you know it's bubba
joe's job down the street it's not some
new guys job i don't know
these are the people i know
this is the brand that's been purposely
embedded in our community they give
money you know they have programs that
benefit people so in general you're
taking that out of a community and a lot
of times renewable energy as the sort of
replacement is not something people have
confidence in is going to be able to fit
that need so you've got a messaging
challenge here you've got a challenge of
figuring out
how to get through to people that
renewable energy is real it's here it's
working it's possible and that's the the
replacement but then you're you're
talking about bubba joe you know the guy
who goes to work at the plant every day
and how do we message around that so a
lot of that has been looking at the
public opinion research on you know what
do people actually think about clean
energy versus coal so again i'm gonna
just motor through these so we can get
to questions um
but you know looking at do people
actually agree
that renewable energy is a solution
um and if you look at these you know
people quote unquote strongly agree
you know and
totally agree all of those things
and
solid majority support
closing coal so all of these things were
a part of several focus groups and polls
that were done
again credit to dave
so credit to public opinion strategies
and
fm3 as they're affectionately known some
great firms that have done this across
the country
just looked at opinion research
so
going to the dynamics on coal retirement
looking at voters of color young voters
who am i talking to republicans
democrats and breaking it down that way
to figure out you know what am i going
to say and you know is it going to fly
or where um you know where does
renewable energy fall on the priority
who are the sources of jobs um
around this and and thinking about who's
affected
um so you know also looking at
place-based polling and you know even in
coal states like montana we actually do
a lot of work in montana and you know
this is a place that you look at who are
again who are the most powerful
messengers in some campaigns we've done
the hunters and anglers so folks you
know
out shooting the bucks who want and the
deer and whatever people shoot
they want to make sure that they have
that protected you know environment
space that they can be they can have the
lands protected that's one aspect of
this um also making sure that the air is
clean that a lot of their their prey
their kill won't be dying off a lot of
the changes that happen when in the case
of new coal um where folks that are
taking land away or
planting or starting new parts of a
business that's not going to be clean
but contribute to more of the the clean
air challenge all of these things factor
into
where are you who's the right person to
be the messenger and what kind of
movement can you build and where
so going back to
the coal fire
power plant retirement um i'm just going
to flip through a little more of this
information
um
this is the other thing about this when
i say that the long term
a big challenge i think that
whatever you're talking about here
whether it be renewable energy coal
climate change has is that long-term
story
so
um
you know why would tyler
why would you think that sort of
long-term aspect is a challenge for
communications
very simple as that they don't in fact
if they think past you know tomorrow or
this week or this month especially in
this economy that's you know a stretch i
think people are concerned with what's
going to change now or next year and a
lot of times we quantify things in the
long term where you know in the long
term if we invest in renewable energy
we're going to have this well what can i
have tomorrow what can i have if i'm
taking this coal plant offline next year
what will be able to be there
so the aspect of answering those
questions it's often a challenge
of talking about things that you know
require a lot of decision-making changes
to happen
so that's a big
red flag around how you're talking about
jobs
how you're talking about renewable
energy coming online
and also around climate change when
you're talking about impacts
there are a lot of things that we know
are likely
and a lot of people want to know what's
going to happen to me in 10 years what's
going to happen to me next year so
that's also something to consider when
you're doing you're creating a story
you're creating a message is how do you
quantify something in terms people can
understand or care about in small amount
of information in the next 10 years what
we've observed over the past five years
people have been alive five years they
haven't been alive 50 years so figuring
that out is also very important
so
also what people are willing to pay is
important that part of of opinion
research is is important i'm going to
motor through these because i want to
make sure that we have enough time for
questions so read fast and these will be
posted somewhere in the future
um
so the other thing is what does it work
is trying to sell something
in a way that people know is not true
um you know for for me this is a big one
because credibility is key whenever
you're you're talking to folks if people
feel like
yeah yeah
not gonna happen
they're going to shut down from you or
think that you know you're trying to
spin them so when you put things in a
frame that either you can't prove or
that there's no evidence around sounds
good but it's likely not going to come
true you're you're also sort of
dooming yourself from from having
credibility and someone engaging with
you around the solutions viability
so that's the key it's that dialogue you
want to have someone interested in
engaging with you and when they don't
believe what you're selling
you know
you're done so trying to figure out
things that people don't trying to
communicate in a way that people don't
buy it's important to know that as well
so here we go when you we talked a
little bit about air quality standards
and here on our coal fire
retirement campaign
one of the economic frames as we call it
so
i hate to use words that i call jargon
but i feel like you get me when i say
frame
so when i say frame
what's your name sir
charlie what do you think i mean when
i'm saying frame
yeah i mean it really
in communications that's the other thing
you have to think about when words mean
different things to different people and
you say them and you're talking in
a way that you get the people here in
whatever yell school of climate forestry
you name it get because they hear them
all the time but then the person you're
talking to may have no idea what you
mean by that or make up their own
meaning so when i say frame in
communications i mean you're you're sort
of putting something in
a way people can understand you frame it
in a narrative box
where you know you're connecting with
their values where they're from what you
know regionally about where people what
people believe where they're from
um in the lens i would say of of
prosperity of freedom so you're entering
the door through a different in a
different way than you would by just
talking about climate or using the word
frame people think frame means what you
put around artwork so figuring out how
to not use those terms like i did i was
just you know
doing a little example there of what not
to do
but thinking about that as well is
important so going to
again speeding through these
where i want to land
is another way of looking at
what we know about issues
one thing that we do
is looking at how the media represent
issues and what we call a media audit
and you look at articles about a certain
issue over a period of time
and you say okay in all of these
articles how was this issue represented
who was quoted so who's talking
um where
and then what's missing so let's say if
you're working on a campaign and you're
trying to figure out
who are the most influential voices on
this
oftentimes it's not necessarily the
folks that are quoted the most but you
can see if you know let's say minority
groups or tribal groups or others who
are most affected
on the issue let's say of coal fire
retirement are going to be powerful
messages and you look at the media over
time and you see none of them are quoted
in articles but the power plant is in
their backyard
that's an area of need that's an area of
action that's an area of movement so
figuring out what you need to do is also
science in communications for movements
figuring out how i can actually break
through i look at messengers who i know
will be effective but they're not that
represented so that's a huge part of it
as well so we look at how in the media
things are being represented who's
talking
um
so in the case of fire power power
retirement it's regulators utilities
investors electeds rate payers
so we look at the mix of stories who's
winning in the story you know going back
to that storytelling who's the hero
who's the villain
what are people saying so
quickly i'm going to shift because we're
likely all here for education
to that difference i'm going to
underscore that difference between
educational communications and
persuasive communication so even if
you're trying to
just inform people
there's actually a way to do that
in a way that works and a way to do that
in a way that's not so effective so i'm
just going to show you a few examples of
that here
so
you know again using people and places
to talk about drought as a climate
impact
this mom's clean air task force is great
at that and they bring the funny they
have a slew of political cartoons that
are hilarious that demonstrate you know
the impact on kids so they have the
recent one on their site is
a classroom and it's the teacher saying
so
raise your hand and tell me
how many of you you know did something
that didn't require your inhaler this
summer so it's you know it's funny um
but it actually makes a point so there's
a way to inform people about impacts
that
is funny is clever
but also gets it resonates so you know
anecdotes
i think for me stories about my family
and the way they connect with things i
was talking to my mom about this project
that we're doing
that's trying to get more weather
casters to make the link
between
the weather extreme weather and climate
change and you know they're in your
living room
they're you know
your guys your ladies who you see every
day they're talking about your community
you know them you feel like you know
them you know they they feel like you're
family and so those folks making that
link
in just sharing information not having
any judgment about it not trying to
persuade anyone
is a powerful powerful tool to us
connecting with a broader audience
so i was you know sharing this with my
mom and she's like oh you should talk to
al
you should so talk to al al roker i
don't know if any of you know him but
he's the weather caster i guess i'm good
morning remember i don't really watch it
but my mom you know big fan of then
willard scott big fan of these guys so
they connect really directly with them
and i also use my family as a barometer
because figuring out what connects with
them i am absolutely not from the green
family you know we are energy wasters we
are you know
from the folks that have never seen this
as their issue and
figuring out if i'm making any sense
with my own family is particularly
important but also using them to tell
stories and most people are seeing the
changes around them and they're trying
to explain them with information and
using those those changes those average
people it is really important in
connecting with more of more of the same
so
again here's here's a another way to
talk about something in a way that
resonates and finding those you know
catchy phrases
like it's junk food for fish we were
talking about nitrogen pollution
and junk food for fish sounds a lot
better than nitrogen pollution but it
gets people in the door with
understanding what you're talking about
so this is another connection um
that is important in how you actually
inform
so making yourself quotable
is is important um
and that's another way to do it finding
those catchy phrases but crafting key
points not varying what's important
scientists this is my favorite thing
that you have to just sort of
pull out of people they like to talk
about what we don't know
before what we know well we're not
certain the certainty level is this and
uncertainty is that and we're not really
sure what's going to change okay what do
you know is going to talk to me about
what you're studying you know shows me
first
um if i ask you a question that involves
you talking about variability or
uncertainty great but in most cases like
i said sound bite nation their reporters
or whoever you're talking about is going
to take whatever
they remember or even just the first
part of what you say
that's it so figure out a way to tell me
what you know what's important about
this
and again on educational communications
some things that that really work and
don't work here's an example of a lesson
learned
why would this be a lesson learned
something that you want to avoid
jorge do you know
anybody why would this be not a great
way
of talking about
who doesn't want to be warm you know
it's just a dirty award who doesn't want
that you know you're you're you're
stating effect but it doesn't sound bad
it doesn't sound like something where
there's risk i mean it's
it's just a degree of warmth so for me
that's that's definitely minimizing the
situation
um
and here's another example of a lesson
learned
it's
talking about what you can't do first
um and
you know
if we had 30 years of data
okay this is these are actual quotes i'm
not going to name names here but these
are actual quotes and major publications
from climate scientists who are trying
to inform and they're just not doing
their best at delivering the information
the other thing here um
you know the person here
he he used
entirely negative wording
so it's
exceedingly likely that climate change
will affect some weather weather
extremes
would be the positive way to say this
i mean
okay well
this person shows it's exceedingly
unlikely that climate change will not
affect some weather
the same things it's exceedingly likely
that climate change will affect some
weather streams okay
i assume that's coming from a climate
site yes it has you can't just turn that
around and say it's exceedingly likely
that some kind of change
like most likely the climate scientists
are very particular about the words and
that's come from the paper
and so and
they've used some sort of statistical
proof and so which
not necessarily but in some cases it
does
and in this case it did and and you have
just demonstrated the greatest thing
that i wanted to demonstrate is that
scientists live by a totally different
set of rules
and
absolutely
absolutely and my only point with this
is that before you deliver that data
this way think about can you say it in a
stronger way and in this case it was
possible but that's the training part
just rip scientists out of that when
talking to the media or actually
communicating across many outlets now
you don't have time to use this kind of
language because you know people but
you're absolutely right it's a different
way of living life it's around you know
accuracy
the process
scientific facts presenting them exactly
the way
that's accurate in the document and not
changing words at all
and you can imagine the challenge around
that with the other side who don't play
by any of those rules and resonate a lot
more strongly with people who don't get
this or don't hear about it as much and
don't question things so i feel like
there's there's that you know
bringing
our credible messengers on climate
sciences who are really trying to
assess data and deliver it and inform to
figure out a way to do that that plays
by the right rules
um but is more effective if that makes
sense and you that was perfect question
so um yeah definitely not saying make
things inaccurate but the challenge is
finding a way to make it higher it help
make the statement higher impact
um thank you
uh so here's another example of
something that um
that i would translate
into
this week's heatwave is a preview of
what we know we're going to see more of
in a warming world
so
this
same statement if someone asked me oh
does you know this
does this seattle's last week's heat
wave in seattle mean that seattle's
going to have another heat wave like
this next year well
this week's heat wave is a preview of
what we know we're going to see more of
in a warming world and that's it you
know you don't have to say well we can't
pinpoint that to a certainty there's no
way to measure that for seattle
yes
what you're talking about is being
persuasive and if you're if this
statement is coming from the scientific
community
then to say what you said would be
not credible
and then there was a point you made
earlier that credibility is important
absolutely if you if you make yourself
sound credible and then you're you're
falsified a week or two later by by
another statement or some other
scientific fact then you lose so this
idea of being persuasive can't ignore
the facts absolutely right and that's
the fact
and if that isn't anything to say
anything beyond that at this moment in
time is not a fact you know it's not
credible so i actually
love that question as well because i
know it comes from someone who's
invested in the science and the
credibility of it and that is a key
but
i think that
most scientists
who would be asked that question and in
this case this scientist as well
by saying this this week's heat wave as
a preview of what we know we're going to
see more of in a warming world wouldn't
believe that that statement is not
accurate
and you and you'd have to probably say
something like it's probably unlikely
well and see that's the difference and
that underscores the difference you're
not if you're talking to the scientific
community
yes but in this case he's talking to a
media representative who's quoting him
in an article
and
this week's heatwave is a preview of
what we know we're going to see more of
in a warming world actually is exactly
what the report was about
um and i feel like that
you know that that statement is
appropriate for the outlet
mm-hmm
i mean this is an accurate statement so
i'm not objecting to anything that was
said there but i'm thinking of her
because
there's nothing
and they just sort of go hand in hand
that's absolutely right and i'm not
saying this is inaccurate i'm just
saying it's not the best statement for
the
for the context for for the medium yeah
well i guess my my feeling is that heat
waves are very low by sort of a local
phenomena and you know it could be a
regional phenomenon as well i guess it
depends on what we're talking about but
if it was a heat wave in the northeast
and i said well you
this is what we can expect to see i
wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily be
accurate for you know 50 years
and so then my credibility is at stake
by saying something like that i could
say you know zonally i mean i could say
something really vague
because that's the fact
but i don't think i could say something
very specific because i don't know what
the hell the answer is
and i don't know i guess that's the
problem when you're asking scientists to
be spokespeople and to be persuasive
you're not going to get better than that
but see again going back to the
difference between persuasive
communication and educational
communication this is not along the
lines of persuading people it's about
how to deliver the information
and you know the scientist is not trying
to persuade anyone quite frankly he's
trying to deliver the information in a
way that people will understand
and i think this one you know again goes
to what we we can't know we can't blame
what we can't do
we know in this report the state of the
climate report shows that
we're going to see more of this in a
warming world and it doesn't go into the
pinpoint of it's going to be right here
it's going to be right there
but what we found by looking at the
trends over decades and you know what we
know we're going to see more of as a
result of these trends is heat waves
like this in a warming world he's not
talking about here there wherever
and it's not inaccurate but it makes a
stronger statement for his quote and i
completely agree and my point back to
your question is this is the challenge
in educational communications around
climate change is figuring out how to
find that balance
before you go into the area of
inaccuracy and violating credibility
which is fundamental especially as
science scientists as communicators as
messengers
but it's also being able to deliver that
information to more than just scientists
so i don't think we're there
i don't think we've answered it today
but i think we have a lot of work to do
yes tyler
absolutely
so
well
i
think there are some scientists that i
would point to that are
able to better deliver information if
you were to ask me who's a hero in the
climate science community i would only
be able to point to heroes that are
heroes for the comic science community
and again public information research is
also key to know who's vilified outside
of that community and know that that
person shouldn't be held up as a hero
so i would say we have a lot of work to
do in not pointing to someone but to
creating more heroes that are diverse
that are credible and that speak to more
people than the ones we have and the
three that you named i think are
fabulous in talking to the base and
carry a lot of weight
are able to inspire which is key
and i think are necessary and valuable
and even james hansen who i think has
done amazing things over the past you
know five to ten years i bring
more people into the fold is becoming
one of those pigeonholed people in his
community so even heroes have you know a
lifespan they're not like batman or
superman who keep returning you know
in re
sequels and things i think that as the
society changes i think we have to make
new heroes and we have to define them as
cool to more people so i'm sorry i can't
point to more people i can point to some
people
that we've worked with who are
like chris field who master and he's an
ipcc scientist coach co-chair of working
group two who just has this way
of speaking about about the
different factors of what the work he's
assessed looks like the impacts of
climate change and communicating it in a
way that
is much more effective than people i've
seen i can actually show you clips where
he's been in interviews where he gets an
interviewer who's trying to make him say
something trying to get him worked up
and he seems he has this way of saying
things simply of remaining calm
of just feeling like your uncle who is
talking to you and not like some guy in
an ivory tower his job is just to crunch
data and look at you know
changes scientifically but someone you
know you would eat christmas dinner with
so i feel like he's he's one of the
heroes i would say in being able as a
scientist to be a good communicator
and
i just think it comes with time and
those kinds of changes
yeah he's done great work in fact he's i
mean
excuse me like you or others i mean that
was a minor story i mean the media
played as minor why was it more major
that could be
that could be but anyway this is an
ancillary point but i just wanted to
bring it up
and he's great as well and he's he's got
some great analogies that i repeat all
the time that have been on npr and the
the channels that actually allow him
time to to cover these things and talk
to people so he's another one absolutely
but my major question
and response to this
gentleman here
professor i guess i'm sorry
i think as a lay person
the scientific community has a
responsibility not only obviously to be
accurate in their findings but to work
with
people like
chiari it's not easy
to come up with
facts that you can that she can use
that can help her persuade people
that climate change is happening or is
inevitable whatever whatever words you
want to put
as as opposed to and i'm not saying you
were doing this but as opposed to
saying well that's not quite accurate uh
let's be positive about it i mean i'm
not criticizing about this it doesn't
matter whether you're criticizing or not
my feeling is that scientists that's not
a scientific role
you know we could be co-opted to to
to be
public speakers perhaps we're not going
to make very good ones you know but if
that's the message you want this is how
we sound but the facts and all the stuff
we do is all published and out there and
ready to roll take it and do it
everything you want with it it's right
there but if you want us to actually
open our mouths right and say something
then we have our community who is right
behind us saying what the hell did you
just say that for
you know and you know we are constantly
being we're constantly thinking about
what the rest of our community is going
to say when we minimize the facts to
some little nugget and and send it off
into space
we're always thinking oh that's totally
inaccurate i hope i don't get catch a
lot of crap the next time i go to a to a
meeting and so we are very careful
because we are attacked by our
colleagues all the time we're not
rewarded for being
to simplify facts we are criticized for
simplifying facts so if you're asking us
to do it you're you're basically asking
us to take a risk
and that's what hansen does he takes a
risk all the time and other scientists
chide him for it and bust on him all the
time it's not something that you know he
walks away with feeling very good about
i'm not saying i agree that there's a
there's a definite negative aspect to it
but the bottom line for me
is that
the big picture is
how are we going to deal with this
problem
i mean how are we going to convince
enough people in this country and around
the world that this is this is something
that's going to and before we move to
the next question i think you're
absolutely right it's it's looking at
the combination between educational
information and how we can deliver the
information more powerfully and the
folks who are actually trying to
persuade people and finding a way to
integrate both and to do you know to
actually move and i hear exactly what
you're saying
it's about maintaining credibility
within your community as much as
maintaining credibility for the
information but i will say the late
stephen schneider has done a really good
job
at helping other scientists figure out
those communication challenges or just
actually entertain a dialogue around
them and there's a lot more work going
on right now
to really figure out this in the
scientific community so i feel like
there's at least more dialogue around
how can we you know not look at people
who do this as pariahs or as you know
doing the wrong thing but as helping to
you know at least share information more
effectively yes i'm sorry what's your
name maybe one more question oh i'm
sorry
okay it's not a question so much as a
comment but you never write an abstract
you either have a positive or negative
spin or you're not worth publishing to
most journals or or even scientific
communities there's always something
positive and negative in there and if
you can't put that into simple terms for
the public to understand what that means
it's essentially what your abstract is
for whether your public's a scientific
public or it's the non-existent general
population
then you're not doing your job
i mean that's that's a personal opinion
there's there's articles that i read
that i go through from different
conferences
the abstract doesn't say anything
positive negative no matter how
interesting the material and the
procedure might be in the middle it's
trash
and scientists remain
very credible information messengers on
this issue
more so than politicians more so than
you know a lot of the other folks that
are in this frame so it's i often talk
about this that it's as much your job as
a scientist to assess the information do
your job talk to your community as to
figure out ways to deliver that
information credibly and succinctly to
more people so a lot of folks see that
as someone else's job
but as a trusted messenger in a lot of
cases and public opinion research does
go to show this it's kind of your job as
well
well and i think that's a good question
because oftentimes people see global
warming as just the warming aspects of
it but we know differently
we know that it's a combination of
different kinds of impacts that actually
that cumulative effect the difference is
is a great way to introduce people that
you know don't think it's just about
this it's about many things and to
understand more about
the different kinds of impacts we'll be
seeing in a warming world you should
just try and find more information and
here's where you go and so i feel like
you're not trying to convince people to
open people and engage them into
what should you care about you should
care about whether you're going to be
able to ski
whether you're going to be you know
under several inches of snow
whether you're going to have drought
conditions floods whatever there's a lot
of information out there
and where do you go to get it it's kind
of the open opening the door not
delivering all the facts and doing it in
a scientific way it's how you engage
people to believe you and to understand
what's at stake or understand what's
changing and to find more information
yes
we're all corporate funders
and live by advertising
selling stock card oil gasoline we're
not interested in climate change being
successful
and i think there are lots and lots many
even graduates from the school
are great spokespeople climate heroes
and folks who are going to call for you
across the country
but wonderful heroes will never make it
on pbs and cnn fox because exactly
because they are a great few of those
and they're great spokespeople and they
work for greenpeace there's a nature
conservancy and they're intelligent and
smart and
i agree we have to do a lot more to push
out a lot more but let me also going
back to my mama
tell you something she said to me we're
having this conversation the other day
you know i saw this piece on the today
show and there were these farmers and
the farmers are talking about how they
can't you know plant their crops at the
same time there's a drought and so
they're having to sell their cattle for
for just meat and these poor farmers and
i was just saying you know she saw a
piece where a farmer was talking on the
today show so things are changing and
people are understanding at least in the
sort of media world how to resonate
better with people even if they're
corporate funded let's say but yes
recognizing the interests behind a lot
of these owned companies recognizing you
know if you're going to be quoted and
you know you're going to be quoted don't
give a lot of information and things you
can't do and have that be the quote
all of those things are important to
consider when you're delivering
information is what do i know about the
consequences of people who take the last
half or the first half of what i say so
what i say has got to be succinct i've
got to have my key points same exactly
the way i would want them printed and
nothing else
so a lot of times people don't realize
that as a scientist and they'll get into
an interview and they'll just keep going
on and on about all the different things
that go into the certainty levels or
what we don't know and all they'll take
is what we don't know
and again it's recognizing the medium
and knowing going to that interview
having practiced your key points and
reporters love the silence so they will
be silent and not ask you another
question just to make you feel like you
need to keep talking so even delivering
the information is about understanding
the possible pitfalls so don't keep
talking they'll break the silence it's
not about you
it's about what you're trying with the
information you're trying to deliver
without it possibly being
mis miscommunicated crafted skewed so
it's a lot of those just you know best
practices and i'm so sorry that we've
gone so far over time that we did not
get the rest of
the um
the presentation or the dessert as i
call it where i actually like to end
with the the positive
the solution story but again i promised
to put these slides online so you could
see more examples of how to deliver so
here we didn't even get to the best
practices of how to deliver climate
information in a way that um you know is
more compelling is more
you know resonating with people's
cultural and um
key values all of those things so
my bad
for keeping it going way too long on all
of these slides
but um i'm just the i'm just the
appetizer in this speaker series so
you're going to be getting a lot more um
in the next few
to four speakers to think about and i'm
just sort of planting the seed wetting
the appetite
that's a good question and because the
do you can you answer that yeah
yeah today my big face is on there which
is very exciting um but yeah that
website has the speaker series and it
talks about then you know all of them
hopefully i'll talk about the rest of
them so
i'll find a way to get this to you and
it's actually a little longer but it has
some good public opinion research in
there it has some good just kind of
lessons learned stuff you already know
no aha moments but a way to package it
to help you remember it
thank you for having me thank you jorge